Dai telescopi al Large Hadron Collider
ogni nuovo strumento scientifico reinventa le domande
che noi come scienziati
e menti curiose possiamo ragionevolmente porci
il high performance computing o HPC
è entrato in quella lista d'élite negli anni sessanta oggi
i computer quantistici bussano alla stessa porta.
Benvenuti mi chiamo conducive to coffee
e sono un ingegnere software qui a IBM Quantum
in questo corso ci proponiamo di insegnare agli studenti
e ai professionisti come il quantum computing collaborerà presto
con le infrastrutture HPC
per fornire calcolo computazionale
imparerai come i computer quantistici
e classici comunicano e scambiano dati
come scrivere programmi che sfruttano entrambi i tipi di hardware
e come questa integrazione apra applicazioni che non riusciamo a risolvere oggi
acquisirai esperienza pratica con hardware quantistico reale
e cluster HPC classici ad alte prestazioni
eseguendo job quantistici insieme ai tradizionali carichi di lavoro HPC
e sarai in grado di interpretare i risultati con sicurezza
e identificare i casi in cui l'accelerazione quantistica
potrebbe davvero aiutare nei calcoli
e dove invece non lo fa soprattutto capirai
verso dove è diretta il futuro dei computer
e la road map che ci porterà lì pensiamo
che questo corso sia sia importante
che tempestivo e crediamo
che combinare queste tecnologie sarà essenziale
per raggiungere il vantaggio computazionale
questo potrebbe avere impatti di ampia portata in vari settori
come la chimica potenzialmente abilitando
una progettazione più rapida di farmaci e la ricerca sui materiali
nella finanza
per modelli di rischio più intelligenti
e il rilevamento di frodi nell'intelligenza artificiale e nel machine learning
per l'ottimizzazione dei modelli in questo corso
approfondiremo le risorse computazionali
i modelli di programmazione e gli algoritmi quantistici
quindi benvenuti e buttatevi
c'è molto di cui discutere